as you start to build more and more
services on top of kubernetes simple
tasks start to get more complicated
for example teams can create services or
deployments with the same name if you
have thousands of pod just listing them
all would take some time let alone
actually administering them and these
are just a tip of the iceberg
it is episode of kubernetes best
practices let's take a look at how
namespaces can make managing kubernetes
resources easier
[Music]
so what exactly is a namespace you can
think of a namespace as a virtual
cluster inside your kubernetes cluster
you can have multiple namespaces inside
a single kubernetes cluster and they're
all isolated from each other they can
help you and your teams with
organization security and even
performance in most kubernetes
distributions the cluster comes out of
the box with the namespace called
default in fact there are actually three
namespaces that kubernetes ships with
default cube system and cube public cube
public really isn't used for much right
now and it's usually a good idea to
leave cube system alone especially in a
managed system like google kubernetes
engine this leaves the default namespace
as the place where your services and
apps are created there's absolutely
nothing special about this namespace
except that the kubernetes tooling is
set up out-of-the-box to use this
namespace and you can't delete it while
it's great for getting started and
smaller production systems I would
recommend against using it in large
production systems this is because it's
very easy for a team to accidentally
override or disrupt another team without
even realizing it instead you should
create multiple namespaces and use them
to segment your services into manageable
chunks creating a namespace can be done
with a single command if you want to
create a namespace called
test you would run keep CTL create
namespace test or you could create a
llamó file and apply it just like any
other kubernetes resource you can see
all the namespaces with the following
command cube see tail get namespace you
can see the three built-in namespaces as
well as the new namespace called test
let's take a look at a simple gamal to
create a pot you may notice that there's
no mention of a namespace anywhere
if you run cube CTL apply on this file
it'll create a pot in the current active
namespace this will be the default
namespace unless you change it now
there's two ways to explicitly tell
kubernetes which namespace you want your
resource created in the first way is
using the namespace
flag when creating the resource the
second way is to specify a namespace in
the animal declaration now if you
specify a namespace in the Y amel the
resource will always be created in that
namespace if you try to use another
namespace by using the namespace flag
the command will fail now if you try to
find your pod you might notice you can't
find it this is because all commands are
run against a current active namespace
to find your pod you need to use the
namespace flag now this can get annoying
quickly especially if you're a developer
working on a team that uses its own
namespace for everything and don't want
to use the names based flag for every
single command let's see how we can fix
that out-of-the-box you're active
namespace is the default namespace like
we saw before unless you specify a
namespace in the resources animal all
kubernetes commands will use the active
namespace now unfortunately trying to
manage an active namespace with cubes
hotel can be a pain fortunately there's
a really good tool called Cubans that
makes it a breeze when you run the
Cubans command you should see all the
namespaces with the active namespace
highlighted to switch your active
namespace to the test namespace you can
just run Cubans
tests now you can see the test namespace
is active if you run cubes you tell
commands the namespace will now be test
instead of default this means you don't
need the names place flag to see the pod
in the test namespace so namespaces are
hidden from each other but they're not
isolated a service in one namespace can
talk to a service in another namespace
pretty easily this can often be very
useful for example having your service
for your team talk to another namespace
with another team service normally when
your app wants to access a kubernetes
service you're going to use the built-in
DNS service discovery and just point
your app at the services name however
you can create a service with the same
name in multiple namespaces thankfully
it's easy to get around this by using
the expanded form of the DNS address
services in kubernetes exposure endpoint
using a common DNS pattern it looks like
this
normally you just need the services name
and DNS will automatically resolve to
the full address however if you need to
access a service in another namespace
just use a service name plus the
namespace name for example if you want
to connect to the database service in
the test namespace you can use to follow
an address database test and if you want
to connect to the database service in
the prod namespace you can use the
following address database dot prod of
course sometimes you do want to isolate
and limit access to a namespace
kubernetes lets you do this with network
policies stay tuned for a future episode
where we'll deep dive into these a
common question I get is how many
namespaces to create and for what
purpose what exactly is a manageable
chunk if you make too many namespaces
that let's get in your way
but if you make too few you'll lose the
benefits I think there are four major
stages that each company goes through
and they have their own organizational
structure depending on the stage at your
project or companies in you can adopt
the relevant namespace strategy so
imagine you're part of a small team
that's working on maybe five to ten
micro services and you can easily bring
everyone into the same room in this
situation it makes sense to launch all
production services into the default
namespace you might want to have a
production and development namespace if
you wanna get fancy but you know you're
probably testing your development
environment on your local machine using
something like mini cube now the
scenario changes you have a rapidly
growing team that's working on 10 or
more micro services it's necessary at
this point to use multiple clusters or
namespaces for production and
development you may start to split the
team into multiple sub teams that each
had their own micro services and then
each of these teams may choose their own
namespace for easier manageability
well everyone might know how the
complete system works it's getting
harder and harder to coordinate every
change with everyone else trying to spin
up the full stack on your local machine
is just getting more complicated every
day now at large companies everyone
doesn't know everyone else teams are
working on features that other teams
might not even know about now teams are
communicating using
service contracts and maybe they're
using service meshes like sto to
coordinate communication trying to run
the whole stack locally is just
impossible using the communities aware a
CD system like spinnaker is highly
recommended and at this point each team
definitely needs their own namespace
each team might even opt for multiple
namespaces to run their development and
production environments setting up our
back and resource quotas is a good idea
as well and we'll cover those in future
episodes multiple clusters start to make
sense at this point but they really
might not be necessary and finally there
are large enterprise companies there are
groups that don't even know about the
existence of other groups groups might
as well be external companies and
services are consumed through
well-documented api's each group has
multiple teams that have multiple micro
services using all the tools I
previously mentioned are necessary and
people should not be deploying services
by hand and in fact they should be
locked out of namespaces they don't own
at this point it probably makes sense to
have multiple clusters to reduce the
blast radius of poorly configured
applications and to make billing and
resource management easier as the number
of micro services and teams using
kubernetes in your organization's
increases namespaces can really make
humanity's a lot more manageable and
give you increased control security and
flexibility I'll see you on the next
episode of kubernetes best practices
[Music]